what is going on everybody welcome to
part 11 of our intermediate Python
programming tutorial series and part 2
of our intro to multi-processing
so in the last tutorial we showed how we
can spawn separate processes but there
was no real communication back to the
kind of starting script so in this
tutorial we're going to talk how to talk
about how to actually retrieve a return
value from our process so first we're
going to start by from multi-process
saying we're going to import cool and
what pool does is just allows us to
create a pool of process workers then
we're going to say is define job job
we'll take a parameter number and for
now we'll just return none times to
really complicated job then again we'll
have if name equals main and if that's
the case we're going to say P now is
equal to actually pool and then we'll
say how many processes we want let's
just say 20 and then we're going to say
data equals P map and then we're going
to map the job itself to some sort of
iterable it can be any iterable so for
example it could be a generator so we
can say range 20 and then we're going to
say P close and then let's print data
and what we're going to get back from
data from mapping is actually going to
be its own iterable it'll be a list of
values from 0 to 20 times 2 so it should
be 0 2 4 6 8 and so on let's see it sure
enough that's what we get 0 to the ROO
all the way up to 38 so so that's just a
really quick example of how we're
retrieving information from our
processes now there are ways to retrieve
processes without mapping a function to
an iterable but real quick let me just
show you like we could do the fall like
it can just be like a list
like this right two-four-six-eight but
it also could just be like a single
value so you could just do four right
and you get returned back in eight or it
could be a string and this does
something to a string and so on so you
can do mapping with just single value
and like I said there are other ways
without doing mapping but I feel like
with mapping it just makes sense because
you can either map a single value if you
really wanted to I'm not sure why you
would have a single value to a single
function within need multiprocessing but
there you go but in most cases you're
going to use some sort of iterable in
this case we've got just four there's
nothing to it but you can put through a
generator - or a list or whatever you
want so you can do that but you can also
do like the following so you could say
we'll do range five here and then we can
copy this and then if you wanted to do
something else like maybe it's a
different function where you only have
the one function but say you want to do
a different function with a different
process we'll just say data - it was
that data - you can of course do this as
well okay so that's how you can get
information back from your processes
really pretty simple to understand but
if you have any questions comments
whatever feel free to leave them below
for now we're going to be leaving multi
processing behind I'll try to weave it
into a much greater example as we go on
the next topic that we're going to start
talking about is object-oriented
programming so hopefully at some point I
will be able to weave in something
simple enough actually I've decided to
go ahead and just do the next tutorial
as being utilizing multi processing with
beautifulsoup to parse multiple websites
at a time so we're going to contain that
little mini project all in one video and
then in the next video we'll be getting
into object-oriented programming so
that's what you have to look forward to
questions comments below otherwise I
will see you in the next tutorial